bring our viewers the full statement
from Nottinghamshire police this is an
update and they say that police are
keeping an open mind over the motive of
the city attack which has left three
people dead but at this time believe
there is no one else outstanding in
connection with the incidents they go on
to confirm some details saying police
were called to ilkerson Road just after
4am this morning after two people have
been killed officers were then called to
another incident in Milton Street where
Ivan had attempted to run over three
people while man is in hospital in a
critical condition two others are
believed to have suffered minor injuries
a man was also found dead in magdala
Road shortly afterwards police have
arrested a 31 year old man of Suspicion
of murder and he remains in police
custody a number of major roads in the
city center will remain closed as a
thorough police investigation is
underway currently police are not
looking for anyone else in connection
with the attacks a team of dedicated
Detective is are investigating these
circumstances surround surrounding these
attacks and we've just got a quote here
from the chief Constable as well that is
Kate main or she said this is a tragic
series of events which has led to the
lives of three innocent people being
taken and left another member of the
public in a critical condition in
hospital my thoughts with all the
families affected by this shocking
incident and we will be working
extremely hard to understand exactly
what has happened we are at the early
stages of the investigation and need to
determine the motives Behind these
attacks and we'll keep the public
updated as soon as we are and are able
to see more we are keeping it open mind
as we investigate the circumstances
surrounding these incidents and are
working alongside counter-terrorism
policing to establish the facts as we
would normally do in these types of
circumstances we do have a man in
custody who has been arrested on
suspicion of murder currently we do not
believe there is anyone else involved in
this incident she goes on to say it is
safe to go into the city center but
there are a number of streets that will
be remaining closed including ilkeston
road where I'm standing now magdala
Street Milton Street and Maple Street
this is so officers can gather evidence
in order to understand what has happened
so that is the latest from
Nottinghamshire police